and the top two lines out for each team tonight
it's kubalik Bailey and Joseph Coffield Suzuki
and Monahan underway as Jake Allen getting the
start tonight he'll drop it off weird to see
Josh Bailey wearing a senator Jersey and playing
center tonight as well on that Top Line power play
for Ottawa Montreal controls kovich floats it to
Center Ice turn over doc kicks it to his stick
and backand in a good stop there by Corpus Salo
and one shot for Montreal as we await our first
goal here at the Bell Center near 7 Minutes in
for this preseason game Jared Davidson some Pace
up the left side Davidson centers right in
front and it squeaks through I don't know if
it's Davidson's goal but he celebrates looked
like ginak was there as well and jiny's going
to celebrate he'll get the goal in the opener
one nothing Montreal makes it happen he turns
hamic eventually loses his edges and crashes into
coroso so shyak puts a puck on net that would have
been stopped but hamic actually takes out his own
goalie feet right here and that knocks it across
the goal line just by a bit zinyak knows right
away better look at it here pu had be saved just
dribbling easily sweeps in and just out of the
reach of Cole Cofield and Doc took a big bump and
back the other way Ottawa trying to strike tuck
to the forehand Reinhardt and that's handled by
Jake Gallen Suzuki the other way well in the power
play SL allows for some speed on the counter as
Joseph draws him in and kicks it back to Reinhardt
Jak Callen makes some pretty nice saves Bernard
tuer trying to take it away Char in his own Zone
he's in the battle doc steals Kirby Doc in front
Trudeau couldn't get a clean shot rebound
score here slowski goes up top and it's two
[Applause] Montreal so the fans want to see a big
guy going to front of the net and finding pucks
and finishing chances and nothing fancy about that
not great skill there but he gets himself to the
right spot where he can use maybe his greatest
assets which is his size in his shot you are
probably apologizing for the previous hit talking
to saard on the face off dot I don't think there
was a lot of animosity there was like my bad don't
sweat it don't do it again kind of thing power
play time again for Ottawa branstrom Bailey Josh
Bailey circles around assess his options goes down
low pass across kubik score beautiful pass Asel
on the tape of kubalik power play goal and it's
two one Hales Thor schmel a nice play now that
is bork's job to take the back door he has to
get down there now ghouly and Allen would like to
do a better job maybe discouraging the pass from
schmel who's a left he's got to Pivot and pass
it oh Allen red sauce getting down and taking it
away like a defenseman here's sovi little bit
of room your sovi drives in forehead dry what
a stop coroso see I'm taking I'm not looking for
a pass looking for another option up turning the
corner and doesn't quite get it up high enough
nice save by Corp pasalo but that's better stuff
from slapovi cor Balo little mustard on that hot
dog G him that he can get four shots a game 320
shots in the year that's that's going to be
close to 50 goals gie nice little move of the
line gie looking for that pass he actually had
SAR the defenseman down low and they couldn't
click Joseph the other way Matthew Joseph oh what
a shot Matthew Joseph a snipe up top with a rocket
and we're tied up at two having a great shot he's
got great Wheels but I wonder if that Cirby dock
stick that got in on the puck fooled Jake Allen
because he never touches it but he kind of gets
in on the shaft of Joseph on the release and I
just wonder Allen look fooled KUB good job to
get it to Joseph and he's away Joseph waits in
shoots and a good stop and why not shoot again
he had success the last time the idea of plan
for Montreal in any at anytime you put on that
uniform it feels special Ridley Greg starting
to give and go sakop in shoots and there's the
first save and test for Kaden Primo Grand strike
across HCK wrist shot that hit a stick and just
went wide rley Greg absorbs contact works it
in deep he's back to work it it was just a cool
moment just to see the owner coming around and
meeting the players and he just seems like such
a likable guy and lot to look forward to in a
walk there's Bailey try to Center that broken
up here's Monahan shorthanded John Monahan
nice little Dipsy to look out as branstrom I
think branstrom actually shot it on his own goal
T sh himself in trouble with a near own goal and
Monahan creating a little bit of turmoil Joseph
deep in his own Zone on the Block for Ottawa for
heatherington Joseph has skated miles in this
game here he goes again Bernard Tucker sets up
Joseph Pace fre shot score he did it again same
side second of the game and it's 32 Ottawa with
three unanswered goals here he is from below his
own goal line comes up late bad Gap same thing I
don't think this hits SAR stick but it makes it a
little bit trickier to pick up the release point
maybe a Rolling Puck as well as he dragged it got
it on edge and Kaden Primo yeah that's absolutely
a roller little knuckler gets past Primo bones has
someone asking for an autograph here in Montreal
PR Docker off the cross far Puck still loose as
Primo scrambling to try find it wrists one in
innocently but through all that traffic maybe
a little tip oh my goodness hit cast didn't go
through Pass right in front oh Primo in his pass
he thought it was behind him and he Stones Ridley
Greg in the dying seconds of this second period
and soloff throws it right out in front one timer
by Greg and that's another Point Blank Chance by
Ridley Greg he actually elevates this one over
the pad it's just a better save by Primo big one
too last minute would have been a two goal deficit
it's amazing how just the smallest gestures from
a team leader mean so much it's not Nicki like
yeah we're going to have copy have a chat no
big deal Bailey back on the puck kubalik Josh
Bailey looks delivers across Joseph had a wide
open net and he missed and he can't believe it
it g is not moving very well all kinds of time
he ring that off the bar I think he might have
char on the four check for Ottawa as Montreal
getting a change in William Trudeau patiently
behind Kaden Primo Nick Suzuki stretching ice
for Coffield and WR shot stop rebound score
Sean mahad and a big welcome back to both players
lighting up the Bell Center to tie things up at
three and connect another nice slash through the
scene by Coffield gets a shot off coroso can't
control it by his hip and like a goal score they
just find the puck faster and to's right or zama's
right there and he just doesn't get his stick
down to take it away from mon Parker Kelly gets
off for a change out through the clear roller
again Suzuki over the line drops for Coffield
Coffield and shoots quick release score surprise
surprise Cole Coffield PowerPlay goal and it's 4-3
Montreal a shot it's not hard to predict
though he's been all over it you love
the way that Suzuki drives the inner Seam for
forcing Travis hamik to stand still that opens
up the ladder play and then Cole Coffield
takes it gets off the boards gets a stick
in a shooting spot Brans gets his blade stuck
outside with Suzuki and he slips it under the
[__] Ottawa trying one last strike three
seconds to go that shot and gouy clears it
to the four boards and the Montreal Canadians
win a pre-season game here at the Bell Center